well time-lapse video shows a beautiful
sunrise in Portland Maine this morning
the Sun will rise a little earlier for
most of us next week at the end of
daylight saving time but a Massachusetts
Commission plans to vote tomorrow on
whether the state should quit daylight
saving time and join the Atlantic Time
Zone instead the move would put it one
hour ahead of the Eastern time zone from
November through February Meg Oliver is
in a Kushnick Massachusetts Meg good
morning Nora good morning this is the
time of year growers across New England
are busy from sunup to sundown
harvesting cranberries and bogs like
this but once the clocks turned back
they're up against an earlier sunset
something a state Commission wants to
change Massachusetts cranberry harvest
peaks in the fall I imagine every hour
of daylight is precious for a cranberry
grower Scott Harding is one of many
growers dependent on daylight to get the
job done you know you have to quit that
much soon you have to everything picked
up before the Sun Goes Down this Sunday
the first day marking the end of
daylight saving the Sun will set here at
4:30 3 p.m. but those long winter nights
could one day be a thing of the past a
report issued by a commission of state
lawmakers found that by moving to the
Atlantic time zone shorter winter nights
would increase the state's
competitiveness in attracting and
retaining a talented workforce why
change it now well look state senator
Eileen Donahue is the Commission Chair
we love to attract Millennials and they
love to come here and work but one thing
we do hear from Millennials is they
don't like the weather and they don't
like it when it is dark when did you
start researching this well back in the
actually 1970s dr. David prayer o is
author of a book about daylight saving
called seas the daylight he says
changing time zones would have a
negative impact on everything from
transportation to finance to
entertainment every live TV show in new
would be one hour later so he would have
the football games and the Academy
Awards and things like that
while I sing deep into the morning could
massachusetts do this alone
well i think anything's possible but
it's not what we recommend you know
massachusetts is not a big state people
travel back and forth over borders for
work for shopping and a lot of
activities and so it would cause
confusion if we went it alone Donohue
wants New York and other New England
states to follow suit but many worry
bringing more daylight to the evening
brings more darkness to the morning
increasing risks for school children
walking to school but the Commission
says they will delay school start times
to fix that gale two thumbs down you
know not for this no we don't need
another time zone looks beautiful
they're sitting in that that cranberry
bog wow that's beautiful Isis a twosome
zone there's you the perfect impact of
light yeah that's right I didn't like
getting up in the dark thank you make me
neither
it's our life